within walking distance who are watching
on YouTube come on over eventually join
us on light sources is by Amedeo this is
over at SLAC the one that Craig
mentioned the free electron lasers which
are slightly different setup than
synchotron and post slightly different
problems Hamid EV is so I divided my
presentation in four parts I will
introduce the Lin acquaint light source
in the beginning to give you an idea of
what a free electron laser is trying to
do when I will talk about how we plan to
build the data system from intra
structure and software point of view I
will give some example of what it means
to do on the fly data reduction for free
electron lasers and then we talk about
this quasi real-time ability to do data
analysis using a supercomputer which is
something that Craig already introduced
in the last in the last talk but from a
free electron laser perspective so VM
LCLs is hosted at SLAC we took over the
linear accelerator that in the past was
used for high energy physics experiments
like Bob are in particular NLCS one took
the last third about one kilometer of
the accelerator to generate electron in
the 2.5 15 GeV range and then sending
these electrons through an undulator but
Wiggles real actress generates photons
but when interacting with electron
themselves generate a resonance that
creates with very short pulses you know
few femtosecond pulses or very intense
of the order of 10 to 12 photons but
when we distribute to the linear
experiment hole and to the far
experimental hole where we have right
now about 7 experiments 7 instrument
rather
where we try to use this 200 MeV to 12
kV x-ray to do to do different kind of
science this is how the new experimental
whole MFR experimental whole look right
now we have a seminal instrument that do
fundamentally very different thing
atomic molecular optical science soft
x-ray x-ray pump probe convenient x-ray
imaging and matter in extreme condition
and we have already at the significant
impact on many area of science from
rosamma structure of protein complexes
that were not accessible before free
electron laser capabilities capturing
bond formation in transition state of
chemical reactions problem extreme
states of matter where we have you know
pet about better watts laser but we use
to excite the sample before we x-ray it
come down the beamline to take a
snapshot of these samples one way to
look at SLS is like one big microscope
but the main difference from the
microscope is that you don't have a lens
that takes care of generating a nice
image but then you can look at to get an
idea of what the sample looks like
typically this experiment will generate
diffraction images but are not that
useful to to to humans to understand how
the sample is actually looking so one
way to look at Ursula's is that instead
of having one big lens we have computing
capabilities that through data
processing and scientific interpretation
which both demanding testing
computational analysis can give you some
insight about the kind of interaction
the kind of sample that was on the
on the beamline as I mentioned this
actually extremely fast we're extremely
short so you can think of them as like
flashes from a strobe light that produce
stop action movies of atoms and
molecules keep in mind that if you
remember the accelerator that I showed
in the beginning I said that we are
using roughly 1/3 of your original
leaner cuts luck we are going through an
essay an upgrade in 2020 called SEL s2
where we will install a superconducting
accelerator invest in the first part of
a linic that will increase the data
throughput by 3 order monitors by 2025
and the pass will actually go from the
120 Hertz that we have today to 1
megahertz by 2021 and then later on we
will use the entire linic and for a
second upgrade that we call SLS to high
energy where we will still operate in
this you know hundreds of kilowatts
megahertz regime but we will we will
operate with higher energy photons today
could you comment on how long the
individual experimental it runs for the
collection looks like yes yes I actually
have a slide that we call a day in the
life regarding the experiments mode I
don't say anything later so let me say
now typically we run between 150-200
experiment per year we run for about
each experiment for 5 days either day or
night alternating to experiment one
during the day and one experiment do
limonite the amount of data that is
collected during these five days changes
dramatically from experiment to
experiment you can go for a few terabyte
to about 250 terabyte per experiment of
course these are the SLS one numbers for
SLS to you know we have a factor of
1,000 more data when we
than we are expected let me show you a
brief movie here that shows how single
particle imaging looks like this is the
sample that is injected along the
midline this is the x-ray that is
illuminating the sample and this is what
we get this is a combination of
diffraction patterns and then eventually
the final goal for single particle
imaging at least is to reconstruct the
electron density the 3d electron density
of a sample at the time that it was
illuminated this is valuable for
reaction kinetics yes yes it can be I I
am NOT an expert
I'm not biologist or my expertise in
building the the computing system for us
to be able to do this kind of science
but yes that's one of the kind of
science that we do trigger for the
reaction that has to be synchronized yes
yes we we have we run what we call pump
probe experiments whether it is an
optical laser that is used to excite the
sample but anything before the x-ray
comes into into the picture and then you
can take pictures of a sample a
different time of the excitation and the
relaxation so they turn it off during
the middle to watch it after they
excited up today yes okay yes because
then there can be a delta with some
jitter between the optical laser and the
x-ray beam and then you use this jitter
to scan the very luxation time but the
relative velocities of the the sample
that was coming into a target range in
they speed up the speed of light those
comfortable no no no I'm talking about
I'm talking about the time between the
optical the optical laser illustration
yes yes no this is a gas injector moving
much yes much much slower or there are
monitors yes it then the injection
itself is is it is an art form it was
one of the main challenges for for SLS
well you know you don't want to have ice
which otherwise would illuminate the
detector and break it you you want to
have the right percentage of the heat
where you illuminate the sample roughly
at 10 percent level if you live in it
too much when you end up having a chance
of piling up multiple multiple
diffraction patterns in the same in the
same trigger you don't want to have too
few of them because then otherwise
you're wasting beam time
so this is one the next few slides are
about four different experimental
techniques that we plan on doing for SLS
- this is one of the first things that
we will do where instead of running
imaging detectors we will have
digitizers connected to a kind of
time-of-flight detectors which gives you
the ability to determine the position of
this electron ion that are generated
when you first pump the sample with an
optical lasers and then later on you
illuminate this excited sample with
x-ray then you generate these waveforms
which are relatively easy to reduce to
extract the time of light and the
position and then you sum all of these
events into an intensive map from
multiple passes this is for us is an
relatively from a computational point of
view relatively easy experiments because
both the computation that is needed is a
relatively relatively low and also the
throughput even if it's challenges for
compared to today's number around or 200
gigabyte per second input to my data
reduction system and then 5 gigabyte out
of it this is a you know it's kind of
how we will start testing SES to 50
percent of the data is for for this this
kind of experiment is a factor of 50
right at least at least we could get
even even more fundamentally you go from
a waveform to a ton of light right so
you go from from a digitizer waveform to
to a few numbers so this is one example
where we have seen a good production
capabilities with ex pcs or photo
correlation spectroscopy things get more
interesting when we start talking about
you know few teraflop tens of teraflop
and hundreds of teraflop for a
computational point of view here the
idea is fundamentally you create the
intensive map for multiple passes by
looking at at the autocorrelation this
is one of the few experiments in SLS
where you look at the correlation
between different events so you look at
how the speckles evolve over time as a
function of Q as a function of M of a
mental transfer there are different kind
of science that can be done with x pcs
again for us the main challenge of X pcs
is that you need to consider events one
after the other for other experiments
like na na crystallography or single
particle imaging every event is
fundamentally independent this is one of
the few cases where you have to look at
events all the time
when the third science case what I was
going to show you is what we call serial
serial femtosecond crystallography of
nano crystallography where individual
nano crystal are injected over in the
ACLS passes this is similar to the movie
that I shown in the beginning when
diffraction pattern are collected on
pass by pulse basis in this case the
data reduction is not done by trying to
reduce the content of information within
one image by by removing the events
where there was no head but
fundamentally the x-ray missed the
sample that was that was being injected
I will get more later about why this is
a better data reduction for nano
crystallography when try to do Fischer
instruction on the image for example the
data analysis for a nano crystallography
is start being computing intensive right
foressi s2 we expect to range from 4
petaflop in 2024 when we start operating
the HD upgrade to 20 petaflop in 2027
when we will operate 16 megapixel
detectors at 40 kilowatts we first
determine the the Bragg Peaks then we
you try to determine what was the
orientation of the sample at the time of
illumination which is called indexing
when you create this intensity map from
hundreds of thousands of pulses and then
from there you can reconstruct them
through an investor Fourier transform
being 3d electron density of a sample
but really the big guns computationally
speaking for SES to will come with
single particle in imaging in this case
you don't have a nano crystal you have
one sample could be a protein could be a
virus and so you don't have a Bragg
Peaks anymore you don't have this
ability to do crystallography anymore
and in this case you need to go through
very complex algorithm typically
iterative algorithms that they try to
use constraints as much as you can about
a priori knowledge of a sample to then
derive the 3d electron density this
iterative nature of his algorithms will
bring us to the exascale regime for
single particle imaging so as I said you
know this is from the user perspective
how does data analytics looks like at VL
sellers first of all we must be able to
get real-time within a one second
feedback about the quality of data
taking are all the detectors
contributing to each event is the hit
rate of them of injector being hit by
the X ray high enough is what respect is
with 10 percent but I was mentioning oh
is it too high or too low and then
within you know one minute timescale we
must be able to get feedback about of
the quality of the acquired data itself
so here is really is very traditional
system is the experiment fundamentally
working and here is is the quality of
the data good enough are we collecting
enough statistic is the signal to noise
ratio as what we expected is there a
resolution of reconstruct electron
density what we expected then during off
shift as I said we to be a one typical
experiment operates either day or night
and during the off day 12 hours that are
not taking data that's when most little
shooting happens we need to be able to
run multiple passes typically of the
order of 10 20 passes over there over
the full data to optimize things like
analysis parameter and possibly change
the code in preparation for the next for
the next shift
this real-time aspect of ACLs is one of
the key challenges
the computing point of view then later
on you know typically of the order of
four months the users keep analyzing
them the data and they must have fast
access to the storage for a period of a
few weeks typically right now we're
retention policies for months Ameena
after four months we move a data to tape
and the users must be able to restore
the archived data to test new ideas to
test new code to try new parameters yes
right back to simple injection
injections of single particles the
orientation is it is an issue can can
orientation be controlled in some sense
no it is not it is not yes you know but
that's not there is no magnetic field
there is nothing that will try to orient
but there are ways to then determine
what the orientation was and I had a
slide about turn about this technique
how much data do you store and where do
you store it like I mean you were
talking about incredible data rate yes
storing that or are you storing some
reduced yeah I'm getting to it yes I'm
getting to it
so as I said fast feedback is a sanction
both on the order of seconds and minute
timescale and to do different kind of
different kind of analysis another
characteristic is that we have short
bursty jobs which need very short
startup time fundamentally by the time
that we submit the job we would like not
be longer than a few seconds so that
when by the time they run they run which
is you know the data acquisition time is
completed we can already look at the
results from put between the storage and
process is critical and also the speed
and flexibility of development the
development cycle is critical there are
many experiments with a very rapid
turnaround and we need to modify the
data analysis during experiments this
characteristic are fundamentally
different from typical users of a
supercomputer to do a simulation for
example so these are an example of peak
throughput this is for the throughput
that we expect starting from today to
the advent of the HLS 2hg we are talking
about terabytes per second so we
fundamentally need to do something way
more drastic than we did in SLS one
where we were storing all the data we
will need to do that reduction on the
fly for SLS - the other challenge for us
is that we are developing algorithms
like the one for single particle imaging
that we require excess scale
capabilities how do we decide that this
was exascale the idea here is that if
you impose the requirement that you want
to keep up with data taking right then
you need to be able to purely utilize
the capability of a machine in order to
have you know enough course that allow
you to pick up keep up with the
throughput from the
the demons so this is how we plan to
build the SLS to data system so as I
mentioned the detectors by 2026 will
generate of the order one terabyte per
second for SES tool we will do something
that we haven't done for SLS one which
is to reduce the data in such a way that
we keep only the science contact that is
needed to do the analysis so everything
that is not strictly required for for
science is thrown away at this level
also connected to a detraction pipeline
we will have an online monitoring system
that will provide this one second fast
feedback analysis capability so that the
user can see what's going on at any
given time otherwise they will say you
know it's like flying blind in the beam
lines if you don't see what is going on
at any point the idea is that this data
reduction pipeline will provide at least
a factor of 10 right now if we look at
the experimental techniques but we
expect this is actually very
conservative many experiments will be to
order magnitude data reduction we will
go on send the data to a fast feedback
storage system where we provide this one
minute data analytics capability and
then finally from there for the
off-shift
analysis we will send either to a
petascale offline computing system or to
access scale capabilities that i've been
asked of the leadership class computing
facilities where we analyze the data in
this off shift over you know for the
following four months and the division
between you know on-site or off-site
will be mainly driven by what kind of
computing is expected for that
particular experiment
the introduction is essential as I
mentioned because it mitigates the
storage button working and the
processing requirement we calculated
that if we didn't do data reduction we
would have to spend roughly quarter
billion dollars to build the best
storage and the processing that is
needed to keep up with SLS to
about your posture feedback is that a
person looking at the leaders of coming
in and then tweaking the algorithms or
is this feedback into the algorithm it
surfaces that automatically modifies
which data's being see if - what
analysis is being done so automatic
operational data will only happen at
this level immediate reduction pipeline
right the users will be able to see
what's going on and they will be able to
tweak the parameters to change how the
data reduction works but this is for is
as a fundamental irreversible effect on
the data on the fast feedback known at
this point the data that we save here is
also the data that we save for the next
four months for the next few years what
happens here is that we try to run a
subset of the full analysis that we run
that we run here so that within a minute
the users can decide what should be the
next the next step should they move to a
different sample should they change the
injector there are many many operations
during data taking that are driven by
the feedback that this analysis is
providing to the users so that could be
as simple as we were non-target with our
sample we need to redo it so yes like
that yes whereas the online monitoring
is is more what code I put in there - no
the only online monitoring is telling
you is the system working properly okay
like other detectors that are missing
all right but it's not really looking
inside equality per se it's not looking
at the quality of a data is looking at
the quality of a date acquisition okay
yes here is when we start looking at the
data okay could you talk about the
- the movement mechanism how do you get
how do you get fix that's out of those
pixels how many per pixel what's the
time yes yes let me get with Lisa slider
that shows how the data reduction
pipeline looks like and then there are
various pictures of some of the
detectors that we that we build for a
CLS one so make a couple of slices it
will come so the main points that I
wanted to do in the architecture is the
introduction of the debt reduction
pipeline and the ability to offload
quasi real-time data analytics to
supercomputers these are the two main
features of our architecture so as I
said this is how the data reduction
pipeline looks like these are the
detectors when if you consider for
example this ESP detectors right it is
one detector but it's broken down in
many different chips and then each one
of them has a fundamentally independent
readout which is what allow us to pull
out this one terabyte per second so it's
something that scale and with the size
of the detectors when we will go to 60
mega pixel detector from the 2 megapixel
two point four megapixel that we have
today for a vaisya spared all we have to
do is to scale up the number of readout
readout nodes the connection between the
front end electronics of the detector
and the readout node will use with PGP
protocol that we developed as lock which
is a fundamentally you know a
point-to-point real-time the firmware
based protocol with some quality of
service capabilities built in
that allow us to connect with all the
custom detectors that we developed for
SLS PGP is not the only protocol there
are things that operate a lower rate or
a lower throughput where we use any
technology that is needed tcp/ip or
serial or anything that is thrown at us
so the big detectors this is what we
look like but we we support almost
anything we did it digitization it
happens on the detector itself
everything that goes here is already
digitized here we may do some
reorganization of the data so that it
looks like an actual detector but here
we have already you know whatever is the
12 bit that are digitized from the
detector itself we may do you know
things like calibration later on but all
them hard real-time operations happens
on the either on the Asics or very 4/10
electronics that is connected to it yes
yes yes
so going back to them data reduction
pipeline this is fundamentally from the
user perspective this is like a black
box connected with a high-speed
InfiniBand switch which connects a bunch
of compressor nodes and then connects to
the fast feedback layer which is going
to be flash based and a bunch of online
monitoring nodes for the quality of data
acquisition that I mentioned at the
beginning the one second time scale
so we went through last year went
through a huge exercise where we started
from the detector rates for each
instrument the distribution of
experiment across the instrument for SES
to the typical up times of this
experiment what we expect the data
reduction to be based on the
experimental technique and then we have
measured the processing time for is just
a mental technique and this has given us
a handle on what we expect the computing
needs for the data redaction pipeline
and for the offline computing to be this
is what we have used for scaling the
data reduction this is what we have used
to ask for computing capabilities as I
said beside the DRP one of the key
aspect of our system is the ability to
offload computing to a supercomputer so
all the exascale kind of experiments
will be offloaded to north or the CLF
and we have been working with North
Korea on this photo science PDA idea
where we stream science data files on
the fly from the ACLS beam lines to
quarry from yes now so the next session
is about example of algorithms just to
give you an idea of what we try to do in
the Nvidia P there are four fundamental
different techniques one is compression
which can either be lossless or lossy it
turns out that lossless given the
typical entropy of our images is not
particularly efficient we can typically
get a factor of two we've not seen we
are still working on it but there is a
chance that we can get the factor of ten
looking for future struction things like
finding the peaks of them out of an
image and move on only the peaks do a
region of interest integrate region of
interest information the angular
integration which is a very powerful
technique binning or transform the data
into a space where the data are sparse
like JPEG style compression or you can
do a veto this is what we will do for
single particle imaging or non
crystallography where because of a very
nature of injector you will miss some of
the samples and so will be able to
detect if one event was a hit or not or
multi event reduction you know MPEG
style correlation of events again this
is something that could help for example
forum X pcs where we do keep correlation
across across events in this session I
will talk about three examples of this
technique one is what we call the time
tool that we will do in FPGA this is
what calculates the Delta between the
optical laser and the arrival of the
x-ray beam we will talk about what it
means to do lossy compression for nano
crystallography from many construction
point of view and what we are trying to
do to do Agra integration which n-dubz
requiring beam Center determination
there are roughly 2025 experimental
techniques that we have identified
I will go through three of them
otherwise it becomes overwhelming so as
I said it's possible to detect the Delta
between the optical lasers that does the
excitation of a sample and we arrive on
the x-ray this is done by taking an
image of the reflection of the optical
laser through a surface which changes
the reflectivity when it's illuminated
the x-ray beam and this allow us to
determine a peak in the signal that then
give us the Delta in picosecond between
between the optical laser and the
exactly this is interesting for us
because it's something that we want to
implement with FPGAs every time that one
of these data reduction capabilities is
relatively stable over time and it's not
depending on too many parameters we will
try to do it within hardware rather than
rather than software and since this is
the same tool across all the SLS
instrument this is a good instance for
us to try FPGA as I mentioned doing
lossy compression is one of them things
that we are studying right now
fundamentally you want to know if doing
this lossy compression will affect very
construction the resolution or very
construction so what we have done we got
a bad image and we added the uniform
random noise the order of 10 plus minus
10 Adu and then we used these simulated
images to go through the construction
and see if there is any difference and
what we have noticed that up to about 10
Adu we are fundamentally getting the
same the same resolution so the 10 edu
28 you is roughly the limit but we are
looking right now the problem is that if
we add this absolute noise the
compression factor at least using these
algorithms that has been developed at
Argonne is not good enough right we need
to go up to 580 use to get
to get the factor of ten that we would
like to obtain so what we are trying now
to look is instead of doing a absolute
noise to add a relative noise of the
order of one percent
sorry ten percent one percent 0.1
percent in this case we can get decent
you know this is a factor seven decent
reduction compared to for example it's
the reduction of our CS better images
this is still work-in-progress really we
would like this numbers to be you know
some somewhere above ten and we need to
determine if this relative error bound
introduce too much noise in being in
their construction it'll be the case
that certain experiments could get away
with more and others less depending upon
what they're doing or is this just a
generic statement
the big advantage of compression
compared to other data reduction
techniques is very general right so
we're kind of so it should be good for
everybody if yes yes you know it's just
a hammer at least for all the Nano
crystallography experience this is what
we should represent maybe twenty percent
of the SES experiment so it it's an
important technique for us
but again you know if you look at stuff
like fish instruction you really need to
do visual structure that is dedicated
for that particular experiment with
compression you can try to get away with
it in other things that we are working
on right now is the determining the
center of the beam because this this is
what allows me to do a radial projection
which is very powerful technique for for
determine if it is a good event if there
is enough information that you want for
that event to move forward and we have
tried different different applications
the typical psychic beam application
uses cannon for edge finding and ransack
for fitting and it's fundamentally not
working for all the science cases but we
flew at it so right now we are trying
with this after inform where you move
from this XY view of the image to a
radial view of the image and then we
apply later on the edge finding and the
fitting and this seems to be much more
robust technique and these are some
example of where our beam Center finding
operate successfully right this is a
typical CS bad image see these are the
readout unit that I was mentioning
before I think we have like 32 of them
in the CS better detector I when
whenever the beam is going through the
middle of the detector it's relatively
easy you know the beam can be anyone can
be on the side of a detector can be on
the corner of detector and this this
code that we are developing right now is
able to adapt to all these different
applications
so as I mentioned beside with the
traduction one of the key aspects of our
system is B ability to offload computing
to a supercomputer
this is Vanetta reduction that I showed
before then we go to a thin but fast
flash based storage layer and when we
move a data over es net to the border
nodes of the chorus of the computer
where we start them when we start the
analysis we do the food reconstruction
and in quasi real-time we send back the
information to the beam lines where the
users can visualize the full analysis in
quasi real-time this XML data analytics
that we exascale is a project which is
part of ECB the exascale computing the
oscar Office of Science and the idea
here is that we are developing both the
algorithms better needed to do the
analysis at least for now lower
crystallography and for single particle
imaging and to scale the capability of
the SLS analysis framework from the
Android of course that we have today 200
of thousand of course that will be
available on an exascale machine and
then finally the infrastructure which is
the automation of the data transfer is
the automation of the submission of the
jobs running the analysis and provide
the feedback back to the users so why is
it important to move from the terror
scale that we adopt today for doing the
modeling of a black spot to the extra
scale that we are aiming for by 2020 to
2024 first thing that we will do the
petascale range is this iota algorithm
which offers a wider parameter search
and we end up with a much higher
acceptance rate for diffraction images
which means that we we can then do the
analysis we have
factor of five more images than what we
can do today
and then eventually with techniques like
the empty pocket on that I will describe
later of ray tracing we will get into
the exascale world and we'll be able to
increase the accuracy now also do the
Nova phasing which means that we will be
able to analyze atomic structure with no
known analog so we don't need any a
priori information to do the
reconstruction so on one hand we'll be
able to analyze more diffraction
patterns which means being able to keep
up with SES to data rate but we'll also
be able to increase the detail very
solution and by scientific payoff
SNS to science
so the next few slides are about some of
them full scale analysis
the first one is nano crystallography
there are significant advantage of doing
nano crystallography LCLs one is with
what we call diffraction before
destruction where then the x-ray is so
intense but so fast that we are able to
take a snapshot a diffraction pattern
before the x-ray completely destroyed
the sample so we are able to completely
avoid the radiation damage and also we
can operate the physiological conditions
which is not something that cryo-em
people can say and again this key aspect
of doing real-time analysis within
minutes provides results that feedback
to the users to take critical
experimental decision
another algorithms that we are
developing within the XFL project is the
few scattering which is the scattering
that comes from any departure of
material structure from that of it
perfect perfect lattice this is a
picture that we have been developing to
show what it means to have diffuse
scattering perturbation to the perfect
lattice this is a perfect crystal of
horses all on the same phase and this is
the diffraction pattern that you can
derive from this perfect crystal of
horses
these are horses that are moving right
we are still in the perfect place in the
lattice but we are moving they are at
different phases and this is what a
diffraction pattern will look like you
still have your bracket you have still
have your Bragg Peaks but then you have
all this cloud of information in the
envy diffraction image that contains
information about all the differences
between the horses in the crystal or you
can have the horses better in phases but
that are fundamentally displaced from
the perfect crystal and then you have
again this cloud slightly different
cloud on top of a other brown spots this
is a development that is being done by
our collaborators at Los Alamos
fundamentally it can provide extra
information and compared to you know the
typical nano crystallography
reconstruction another algorithm we are
working on within XML is the M tip for
single particle imaging this is an
algorithm that tried to determines at
the same time the orientation the
intensity and the phase of the single
particle that was illuminated by the
x-ray
the idea is to reconstruct a 3d
structure on the second particle
using the diffraction before destruction
that I just described we get we collect
thousand of diffraction patterns
randomly oriented single particles as I
said we don't try to orient these
particles in any way and then even if we
cannot measure the orientation of
dividual particles or the faces of the
fashion pattern and tip through this
iterative algorithms can deduce these
two unknowns orientation and phase given
some constraint this is the first
example where this group which is the
camera group which is a collaboration
between different offices within the
office of science as done by imposing
their with symmetry over the other with
samples they were able to deduce both
the orientation and the phase of the
fracture patterns so this is a very
powerful technique but it's very
computing intensive the iterative nature
of the office process this is what will
bring SLS to analysis within exascale
then finally we are developing a
framework for analysis that will be able
to satisfy any experimental techniques
any algorithms but is frauneder and what
we are working on right now always
within exascale is the ability to scale
from the androids of course that we have
today to hundreds of thousands of course
we are doing this by adopting this legal
framework that will allows not only
better ability to overlap IO and compute
but above all to provide portable
performance on new architectures and
this is becoming particularly important
for us it looks like that even if most
of the access computer will be
accelerated architecture they would be
fundamentally different architecture and
our hope is that by adopting Legion we
will be able to port and optimize the
SLS analysis framework relatively easily
from one architecture to question
currently doing some of the stuff on the
que eles adverse have you also worked
with we are doing we are doing summit
this year okay yeah that would be the
first time where we try to bring the SLS
or are you going to use region on
that's video this is how our system
looks like we fundamentally try to
offload one event to each car when we do
calibration we run the science specific
algorithms and then legion is what puts
together the communication across the
course before we write the result
visualize and provide logging
capabilities right now instead of Legion
which is MPI religion which we we hope
to get better Portability and previous
code from the camera group yes yes that
that's exactly very right we can do this
part of this development in parallels
the the framework on one side and then
we plug in in this box here what is
needed
another key aspect of SLS too is that we
will try to move more towards automation
we will ask the users to do less and
less to focus on the experiment side and
not whether to fight with good analysis
at all the time and so one of the things
that we have done within XFL at the end
of the last year was to automate all
these steps moving the data starting
analysis running the algorithms and then
visualize the information back to them
to the users so the last slides instead
of doing a summary slides I would like
to show you a video that we developed it
is five minutes video so we have time
that shows them how we put together all
these capabilities right the Nano
crystallography algorithm development
together with the scalability of
energy's framework together with this
resource of castration between the beam
lines and husk
that coherent x-ray laser at SLAC
National Accelerator Laboratory it's one
of the nation's most important tools for
studying materials at the atomic and
molecular scale
you see is a mish cxi back straight
light the structures of biomolecules
research you serve around the world come
to LCLs to study these biomolecules
using a technique called serial
femtosecond crystallography
in this technique diffraction pattern of
crystallized proteins are measured on a
detector
complex' computer algorithms are been
able to analyze and reconstruct a topic
structures from these measurements
[Music]
however I'll CLS's x-rays are in great
demand and in order to obtain
high-resolution structures of a given
biomolecule researchers may need to
capture more than 100 thousand crystal
diffraction pattern
[Music]
LCLs currently runs the analysis in
parallel over about 1,000 cores but it
still takes hours after the data are
collected to determine the structure of
the protein
the data analytics at the exascale for
free electrons leadership project or exa
fel in short will pair LCLs is
crystallography data is dense high
bandwidth pipeline and the DoD high-end
computing facilities to allow
researchers to analyze their data in
minutes
vo web browser interface
as part of its first year data challenge
the XM field project recently completed
a demo where a user and a she ate the
crystallography analysis on a web
browser while the data are being
collected
within seconds the crystallography data
to be analyzed are sent from LCLs to the
National Energy Research scientific
computing Center supercomputers over ESF
yes that data pipeline provides
high-performance high-speed service to
more than 50 do weave research sites
[Music]
slack is connected to ESS at 1 by 100 G
with a second 100g addition expected at
the coming months which would become
these fronts are urged three-dimensional
space
The Verge database GUI is automatically
updated to reveal the first look at the
electronic structure of the biomolecule
lysozyme crystallize with you terbium
the experimenter can then study the
structure near real-time and
interactively
researchers connected via web browser
can receive feedback about the progress
of the analysis from anywhere in the
world within minutes of the experiment
starting
with each set of newly analyzed runs the
molecular bottle improves as more data
are merged in
as a proof of concept this demo tries to
replicate a scenario for LCLs to where
data reduction has been done locally
close to the mean lines and only the
useful Bristol kids are sent over to
nurse
in the demo we analysed 140,000
diffraction patterns amounting to 600
gigabytes of data processed by 30 mm
computing cores on nursed for ep2
supercomputers within minutes
[Music]
the LCLs to upgrade will increase the
x-ray laser frequency from 120 pulses
per second to roughly 1 million pulses
per second increasing the Associated
data rate several thousand times over
assuring LCLs into the excess Kimmel era
and pushing the boundaries of excess
gales real-time computational intensity
exit FPL will be instrumental to the
development of data analysis techniques
for LCLs to
[Music]
every secret except with what to show
all right thank you very much so just a
few minutes here to take a couple
questions Josh survey in general and the
built by a decision of different
software components how how do you
generally evaluate commercially
available software and then decide yes
we're gonna just use that either open
source your paper or license or just
build your honor so that's really
different components right one thing is
the overall framework is what yes
another one that provide the scalability
that is various completely open-source
it adopts some
typical open-source Python tools is
written both in C++ and Python and it
adopts some Python code that is being
developed specifically for beam lines
which psychic beam idea
where we try to provide them a bite on
API to a note a bunch of high
performance C++ course up to now we
never adopted any commercial software
and I have to say one of our main
competitor for PA sana was was MATLAB
and the main the main difference the
thing that really changed everything for
be asana was when we moved from c++ to a
Python interface only then people
started adopting p asana and drop and
drop MATLAB regarding the algorithms
this is very specific techniques that
are typically developed by by by
universities there is a problem that
many of these universities institutions
they film competition with each other
it's a very different environment than I
energy physics for example
everything is open source here the data
is given access only to the experiment
and to the users but run that experiment
and the software except the one that we
developed that we make available to
everybody that's our main job the
software is not always shared there are
for example there are you know competing
nano crystallography software packages
no problem out there and that is
something that hopefully as we get more
and more into software development we
can we can intervene and make all the
stuff available to everybody
because right now what happens is some
of the groups that have done the
development we use this leverage to get
in know into all the groups that do
science in Ursula's which is not what we
want we would like for you know
relatively group with pis metal not you
know exceptionally
connected to two other groups to be able
to have great ideas come to SLS and do
science so that's one of all the
initials as I as I see it
on my job to collect all the software
from the different facilities and make
it available to everybody
two veteran averse to movement so we
talk about the reduction are you ever
discarding information that you might
need Lee it's possible yes how do you
know in advance that you don't need it
do you discuss with the scientists yes
yes then we are going for very painful
process right now where we interact with
the users to to decide what the data
reduction software will look like let me
say it won't that there are a plenty of
mitigations in the system for example
we'll be able to pre scale the data that
comes out of the different - employment
social events will go through no matter
what
so offline value can you can verify that
we are not discovering any useful
information the other mitigation is that
we privatize the debt reduction so that
is relatively easy for the users to
change what what goes in and what goes
out it is a big deal for SNS one we
saved all the data so now to convince
the users that we are able to do fish
instruction and not throw away any
science is a charge now it's something
that we need but at least you have the
data and prove you could prove to them
that what you're doing yes is is right
yeah we will save a subset of a dinner
no matter what
also an experimenter is a few days so we
will have time to correct and and avoid
throwing away the actual science once it
but you know this is something that I
energy physics APUs all the time exactly
no that's why I'm wondering the there is
a fundamental difference between energy
physics and what we do in energy physics
typically you have a cross-section that
determines the rate of useful events in
many of these events I hope this
experiment all the events are useful but
that's also what the LHC experiments are
turning to because so far we've not
really found anything that stands out
there's more cross section so you really
need to look in the power cloud you
really need to make the most of long
enough so we have similar challenges I
think so
I was curious I mean I think it's really
cool how this data converts to this
detailed structure that you were showing
of the proteins I was just curious I
mean what does detail it was a little
bit more of a taste of what science
you're getting
so the typical solution is a understand
scale we can get down to one to answer
on these on these constructions much
better again this is not my area of
expertise but fundamentally it allows
you to understand how once you have a 3d
electron density of sample it actually
understands how you tell us with the
rest of the world right so you can have
an idea of what the weak points of a dye
or something
if I get out how our one one other
science example that let's illustrate it
is something like photosystem 2 is a
very large macromolecular you know
complex has been observed in its photo
catalytic processes with this technique
so if you want to observe photosynthesis
that's one of those lights here
sort of down at the information
architecture level when you're for large
systems like this computation way and
data storage choice what sort of data
integrity analysis do you do - I mean
when ten to the minus twelfth bit error
rate when you have a big numerator and
you get a hit and your meta data or you
have to worry about it do do just by
data integrity from the infrastructure
provider or do you do your own analysis
perhaps making a distinction between
observational data which is more robust
and other data metadata that's more
sensitive I mean from the moment that we
read out from the front end electronics
all the data goes through checksum at
all the stages okay is that what you
were asking or its there's the data
integrity device there's error detection
error correction the cost of that at
multiple stages I'm sort of thinking of
you know planetary probes where this
this issue has to be corruption
corruption of various portions of the
communication in DeAnda for the kind of
experiments that we do if a bunch of
pixel it's not it's good it's not going
to affect us right after the data has
been written the first time from that
point on we we can guarantee that there
is no error being applied to it but it
is true that you know we could have at
the you know it's a ASIC level we could
have no modification of the error
content of the content of all these
pixel information but from fundamentally
that is not going to affect the science
that we do later
you know even if we have a few pixel
orderly 16 megapixel detectors where the
information is not correct is not going
to fundamentally affect the
reconstruction if you notice you know
VCS pair there's all these empty
information across the Asics do you not
and we can fundamentally take that in
into account and not affect the
reconstruction capabilities so
fundamentally we are resilient to the
flipping of information at even any
other questions
oh it's thank ever do again
[Applause]